[Musique]
il y en a certains qui voudraient me
faire passer pour le méchant de cette
histoire
[Musique]
notre destin est il tracé dès la
naissance
ou via t-il un jour
frapper à notre porte
chanteur de memphis dans le tennessee
faites lui un accueil chaleureux sur la
scène du rail
monsieur
trèfle est
totale chez le coiffeur zollinger à ce
moment là j'ai vu ce garçon maigrichon
se transformer en super héros
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était lui mon destin
je souhaiterais être votre manager
monsieur presley
à vous envoler je suis prêt près
toute l'amérique ne tournera que
si je peux pas bouger je peux pas
chanter
des gens qui voulaient mettre en prison
à cause de ma façon de bouger mois il
pourrait mettre en prison pour avoir
traversé la rue mais toi tu es un blanc
ses lèvres et
la façon de chanter est un cadeau du
pont d'yeu vie n'y a donc rien de mal
[Musique]
c'est tragique mais ça n'a rien à voir
avec nous ça a tout à voir avec nous au
[Musique]
mot
ils vont
oh
un pasteur m'a dit un jour quand les
choses sont nous dangereuse à dire
chante chante
[Musique]
bientôt j'aurai 40 ans
et personne ne se souviendra de moi
somme
j'ai besoin de revenir à celui que je
suis vraiment
et qui tuent nuit
[Musique]
tu t'en tirer meilleur parti de tout ça
tant que je peux
ça pourrait finir par être l'adage
toi et moi nous sommes de la même graine
deux enfants étrangers solitaire en
quête d'éternité
[Applaudissements]
grand spectacle sur terre
elvis a quitté le bâtiment
[Applaudissements]